[Music]
studies show the protection provided by
covid19 vaccines may fade over time
[Music]
that's why germany has announced a
booster jab campaign the uk and france
too
israel is already pressing ahead
we're the first people in the world who
are doing this
we're in the middle of a big spread of
infection
but the world health organization says
supplies should go to poorer countries
is a third vaccination dose in wealthy
nations rarely justified
[Music]
welcome to our kovid 19 special i'm
robots in berlin now there's clearly
vast inequality in the way that
coronavirus vaccines have so far been
distributed around the world while many
wealthy nations have jabbed more than
half of their populations billions of
people in poorer nations are unprotected
in kenya less than three percent of the
population has been even partially
vaccinated against covert 19. dw
correspondents mario muller and felix
moringa sent this report from gatanga
[Music]
a family in grief in less than two weeks
three of its members have died of covet
19.
it went very fast
james monge tells us he buried his
father just a few days ago and his
grandmother the week before today he's
barring his uncle
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we are traumatized
because it's not so easy some people are
with them tweets ago they had no issue
then all of a sudden in a span of less
than 10 days they're all gone
at his father's grave he pays respect
before joining his family at his uncle's
funeral
james is struggling to understand what
has happened
so too is his aunt
thank you
my heart is in a lot of pain
i don't know what to say
if people had gotten the vaccine
i think even those who were sick
the family is convinced their loved ones
could have survived had they been
vaccinated
with many rich nations having inoculated
more than half of their populations and
even started to roll out third booster
jobs poor countries are lagging behind
the who says the vaccination rate is as
low as one percent across the continent
health experts say
this vaccine iniquity is also a moral
issue we cannot start administering
booster shots
when some of us
don't even know
if we will be able to get a second shot
it's just um a really great injustice
and it's unfortunate that who's hands
are also tied
many kenyans we meet in nairobi agree
they have the obligation to help so i
don't think if it's something bad they
can do it
since we all need the vaccine they have
protected their people and their
citizens but they have neglected these
needy countries if you find out that we
are not vaccinated then the rate
at which the virus will be spreading it
will be very high and i think that's the
reason as to why most of we africans are
dying
at the burial james duoti a member of
parliament tells the family he did
everything he could to purchase vaccines
for kenyans
we put in money to buy vaccines but one
of the challenges of the vaccine is that
they're not available anywhere globally
africa has been african citizens have
been to their second-rate citizens
the surviving family members were tested
negative but they're still worried
because they don't know when
and if they'll get vaccinated
if vaccinated granny might have died
because she was old but the other two
could have survived
until low-income countries get their
fair share of vaccines family tragedies
like monica's will continue to happen
well let's speak to maduka pai who is a
professor of epidemiology at mcgill
university in canada thanks for joining
us on the kobit 19 special i mean given
that so many people
are unvaccinated in less wealthy nations
is the idea of providing third jabs to
people who are already protected to some
extent is that just the wrong thing to
do
um absolutely i believe that is the case
i think we have to understand that
the vaccine supply is almost like a
zero-sum game right now if rich nations
have already procured millions of
billions of doses and they are
pre-ordered for booster doses the amount
of vaccines available for other
countries is very very limited so in
that situation it's literally like
stealing away from poorer countries that
desperately need the vaccines and
holding it to ourselves which is exactly
what is happening right now and we end
up with a situation of 3.5 billion
people
half the world's population with not
even a single dose covered while the g20
and the g7 pretty much have procured
nearly 90 percent of the vaccine
supplies the existing vaccines work
quite well with the current dosing
without boosters except in a small set
of people such as people on organ
transplantation and immunosuppressed in
them a third booster makes sense but not
as a population right strategy no
but we have seen the impact that new
variants can have particularly delta so
aren't governments right even in wealthy
nations to be seeking to protect their
citizens against
newer versions of coronavirus
so if you look at uh how many million
people have died because of the delta
variant in india
you get a sense of what the delta
variant can do in a partially vaccinated
or completely unvaccinated country what
happened in india then happened in nepal
then happened in bangladesh then
happened in indonesia now vietnam now
iran it never ends and in a population
where only two percent of the population
is covered by a via vaccine like in
africa the delta variant will decimate
the country or the continent that's
exactly what happened in india we may
have lost nearly four to five million
people in india
due to covet pandemic so we know how
devastating delta can be and here we
have a population in rich countries
where
80 percent might be vaccinated so
getting an additional
boost protection uh increasing the
efficacy by a few percentage points in
rich countries versus taking those
vaccines and vaccinating completely
unvaccinated vulnerable people there is
not even a question the public health
map clearly tells you vaccinating the
unvaccinated is always more impactful
than boosting somebody who's already
pretty much protected so it's your view
that as long as there are people in the
world who would want a vaccine and have
not had it we shouldn't be offering
boosters to anyone
except the immunocompromised the the
seriously immunocompromised people folks
like transplantation that's the group
for which the us fda just announced last
week that it's okay to give the third
boosters but not on a population-wide
basis and that's where my biggest
concern is if canada america germany is
israel we all start vaccinating
ourselves again and again and again we
have taken away a giant share of the
vaccine supply away from the hands of
low and middle-income countries that's
the brutal reality
do you have any hope sorry to interrupt
you but do you have any hope that those
vaccines that are maybe surplus in some
countries can be redistributed is that
realistic i'm quite despondent i'm quite
despondent i'm not seeing any
enlightened leadership from the g7 or
the g20 or any rich nation for that
matter we've i think we've lost the plot
on global solidarity i think global
solidarity is a lie it's a kind of
buzzword people throw around but we
really don't mean it in our actions
okay
from mcgill university thank you very
much for joining us on the kobe 19
special bringing us your insights
thank you for having me
and now it's your turn to ask the
questions let's hear from our science
correspondent derek williams
[Music]
what do we know about whether vaccines
reduce the risk of long covet
long covid is a catch-all name
describing a wide range of persistent
complaints in people who went through a
coven-19 infection most estimates say
the condition
affects
at least
one in 10 people who survive the disease
so we're talking
millions of sufferers worldwide
even though long covet is often
associated with with patients who had
severe coveting
many who had much milder cases also
just can't seem to shake it for for
months afterwards so
what does the data say about
breakthrough infections in people who've
been fully vaccinated they're rare
and breakthrough patients usually
experience mild symptoms
but since even a mild infection
apparently sometimes triggers long covet
too
how much of a threat does it pose to
someone
who's been vaccinated but subsequently
gets cobit 19 anyway
are they at less risk of developing the
syndrome
many of the experts i read think that
long covet will indeed prove to be less
common in in breakthrough patients but
their opinions also seem to be based at
the moment on kind of a lot of guesswork
there hasn't been much research
published on the topic so far because
long-covered studies by their very
nature are going to be long term and
because
even with the delta variant causing new
spikes of infection in many places
breakthrough infections still remain
much more the exception than the rule
but the pile of evidence is slowly
growing um one small scale study out of
israel
didn't rule out long covet in
breakthrough cases it tracked around
1500 fully vaccinated healthcare workers
for about three months and identified
39 breakthrough infections in the group
around one in five of those breakthrough
patients still complained of lingering
symptoms after six weeks
but that's just one small piece in what
promises to be a very complex puzzle
[Music]
and just finally more and more people
are taking up walking as part of their
daily exercises because of the
coronavirus pandemic according to a
forces survey 52 of respondents in
germany at least said they have taken a
stroll more frequently now than before
the pandemic in light of closed gyms the
study also found that exercise at home
has become more popular too
you